hello there reject nation we're going to
be checking out from the cosmic wonder
today
news that has been all over our
notification bells today
deadpool 3 coming in marvel phase 5
deadpool 3
announcement like i said it's a whole
bunch of websites are reporting on this
i wanted to check out warren
specifically because we're gonna be
going on the cosmic wonder next week and
i wanted to let you guys know that we
are gonna be doing a collab with him and
also this sunday i'm gonna be putting
out a very special
video pretty big announcement and i hope
you guys hit that subscribe button and
click that notification
bell because especially if you've been a
fan of the channel for a while or if
you're brand new i think you're going to
want to check that video out it's big
so keep a lookout sunday around 10 30
a.m anywho let's watch
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marble and look how
excited warren sounds
pool is coming to the mcu we've all
known this for a while but it looks like
i don't know any details yet
nor do i perhaps maybe even sooner but
it looks like
no later than phase five as deadpool is
finally
making moves and we have some official
reports today that give us brand new
deadpool 3 news so we're going to break
it all down but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe for your chance to win
a zombie hulk funko pop by picking a
winner next friday
so today's report about deadpool 3 is
coming oh from deadline specifically
okay
news outlet and they have an exclusive
report about deadpool 3 stating that
marvel studios and
disney have hired the mollino sisters
wendy molyneux and
lizzie molina to write deadpool 3 along
with ryan reynolds of course
the mollino sisters are writers for
bob's burgers and
finally some real news
now since they're already getting the
writers right now they are technically
in pre-production they're going to start
writing the script soon since they have
all of their writers so the script is
coming very soon and once the script is
done usually
and the crazy thing is the timing of all
of this they're starting a lot earlier
than i think a lot of us
expected them to marvel hasn't even
started production on some of their fans
and now things are already moving for
deadpool 3. this means that deadpool is
definitely going to be coming in phase 5
but it actually could come
even sooner if we consider the fact that
marvel studios might not actually
put deadpool in their mcu lineup there
have been reports and rumors stating
that everything
that happens to deadpool will exist in
the mcu but it's kind of going to be
like
agents of shield where things that
happen in the mcu affect the deadpool
movies but things that happen in the
deadpool movies don't really affect the
entirety of the mcu now i'm sure that's
not going to be
entirely the case because i'm sure we're
going to have deadpool team up with
people like spider-man and the avengers
at some point
yeah it'd be foolish not to but it's
kind of like the spider-man movies they
exist in the mcu but they're never
included in marvel's phase four lineup
when they do their announcements so we
could have a similar situation with
deadpool he might not technically exist
in the lineup that marvel announces but
the movie could come out
during that time and what that actually
means is we could actually get deadpool
3 before
phase 5 even starts but right now
there's no doubt that we're going to be
getting deadpool by the end at least
of phase 5 of the mcu phase 5 should
technically
end four or five years it's happening
it's happening
[Music]
today is making moves with deadpool 3
and we're getting it a lot sooner than
expected in phase 5 and hopefully if
we're lucky even sooner
be sure to let me know what you think
about this awesome news in the comments
down below and let me know who you would
like to see deadpool team up with in the
mcu be sure to hit the like button and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest deadpool and
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof wowie wow wow
well it's some big information right
there yeah man that's cool
reese and paul wernick they wrote the
other ones right they wrote the first
two
so this is this is going to be a
different yeah
it has to be a different thing
altogether just considering the fact
that it's
within the mcu even if it's along the
lines of what warren was talking about
in this video
where it's not like fully part of the
phase
i have to treat it as some alternate
sidebar thing yeah at the same time
though it's still a part of the mcu now
so it's gonna have to be a different
thing
i haven't seen much of bob's burgers
i've honestly only seen clips i don't
think i've seen a full episode i know
it's quite a beloved show people think
it's really really funny i don't know if
you've seen it yeah i've seen
not the whole show but i've seen several
episodes and i can attest
is is very funny yeah and i imagine that
kind of humor would bode well for
something like
deadpool and then you know it's ryan
reynolds he's going to be working on the
script as well so
it'll still have that sensibility
regardless i guess the big question
that's still looming here
is beyond the fact of how much will this
tie into
the other mcu films what exactly will
they do because i feel like it could
still be its own thing and you could
have other
mcu characters cameo and there's so much
so many of us have talked about that
constantly already
big question now is will marvel allow
this to be rated r
that's the big thing you know exactly
and i i still feel like it has to be
rated r
and and if they do that that makes it
even more justifiable to not have it be
so specifically linked in or tied in as
strongly to its phases you know what i
mean
yeah exactly and i think that would be i
mean they could give deadpool
like the possibilities seem endless to
me they could give deadpool his own
joke phase between phases four and five
if they wanted to and yeah
i think they could work with a pg-13
rating if they just choose to embrace
and make a joke out of it but i feel
like the soul of deadpool really would
be inhibited
by being crammed into that box and so
yeah i can envision a future in which
like
maybe in the greater mcu people
occasionally mention or acknowledge
deadpool maybe even slag him off as sort
of like a
you know i can totally imagine the core
vendors being like oh this is totally
like
something deadpool should be handling
why are we you know a joke like that but
yeah
having a side universe where we might be
able to get any number of the
avengers or marvel characters into the
craziness of deadpool
yeah without that having to affect their
overall story and timeline seems like a
potential for a lot of fun especially as
you're opening up
the multiverse and whatnot you know so
the possibilities of having everything
coexist are a lot
more available to us i mean with the
multiverse opening up it allows for any
possibility to make this work
yeah exactly he could just literally
exist in some other
part of the universe and that's as easy
done to write it off as possible right
although i am curious though because
deadpool 1 and 2 i thought were
wonderful films obviously i feel like
most of us love those movies for rhett
reese and paul wernick to not be
returning
though their films are usually pretty
hard are with a big heart
that's how i associate their movies yeah
hard art comedies with a big heart i'm
kind of baffled
that they're not here and i wonder what
what it could be
of why they're not writing this one yeah
which is a bit of a bummer but at the
same
time i'd be less put off by it
if it wasn't the first deadpool movie in
the
mcu if that makes sense i see if it was
just deadpool 3 under the fox umbrella
and that was it
then it'd be like what the hell were
paul uh rhett reese and paul wernick but
the fact that they have to
mix it up and make it a little bit
different and not just
feel solely like it's only deadpool 3
but now it's mixed in with the mcu
i feel like you got to have a bit of a
different voice to it yeah
that's light adjacent maybe i think i
just want this to really be good and i'm
justifying it if i'm being honest
yeah and that is something that those
two writers you know had a big part in
shaping the voice and obviously you
still have the fulcrum of ryan reynolds
and yeah the one thing i would want to
know is yeah in the past we've seen
situations in which great creatives
don't necessarily
jive with marvel's way of doing things
and i just hope it's not
that you know maybe they had something
else they wanted to work on or maybe
everybody decided yeah it's time to get
a slightly different set of voices in
here to
keep it enlivened and keep it fresh and
and whatnot and if that's the case then
i don't mind at all because
hey i mean again i from what i've seen
of bob's burgers you know it seems like
they're a pretty cool duo to tap
and it's in the spirit you know you've
got another duo of writers who
seem to be content working together so
as long as it's under the right
circumstances i'm actually kind of
excited to see what they come up with
all right guys well
deadpool three some actual news they're
not rumors of real news for a change
what do you guys think about this are
you okay with them changing up the
writers does it not really
matter to you at the end of the day it
seems like ryan reynolds is the writer
it always comes across what do you think
yeah
subscribe click that notification bell
keep a lookout for that video on sunday
keep a lookout for when we have that
collab with warren up and last but not
least
bradley bledsoe so bradley we missed
your shout out last month when you
pledged we gave you a shout out at the
beginning of this month
but it's only right that you get two
shout outs
in the same month so follow him on his
youtube channel
follow his music he's a wonderful
creative artist
i believe i need to check my instagram
messages
but i believe he just adopted a child
with his
hot ass sexy wife who i fantasize about
all the time
you tell her that news bradley and if
she doesn't like it you tell her i'm
joking and if she
likes it you tell her greg's
willing to fly over there and
i take your child away he talks to me
about this fantasy a lot
this went down a different route it's
uncomfortable i'm like dude you got to
respect bradley and why do you want
shout outs from just a burgeoning family
and you want to step in and break that
up you know
you're like your wife is yours you
shouldn't share her with me
all right
[Music]